House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Ned Stark's older brother, Brandon Stark,
played a big role in the prelude to Robert's
Rebellion.
Brandon Stark was the heir of Rickard Stark,
the Lord of Winterfell, and the older brother
of Eddard, Lyanna and Benjen Stark. He was
killed by strangulation by the Mad King
when he protested the kidnapping of Lyanna
by Prince Rhaegar Targaryen.
His father Rickard died along with him by
wildfire. This brutal act triggered Robert's
Rebellion,
the civil war that led to the removal of House
Targaryen from the Iron Throne.
Originally, Game of Thrones season 1 was to
feature a scene where the Mad King executes
the Starks.
It was filmed and put in the trailer, but
they eventually decided to edit it out.
Brandon was in appearance and character very
different from Eddard.
He had grey eyes, and was tall and handsome.
Brandon was absolutely not shy about taking
what he wanted.
He was rather hot-blooded, a trait their father,
Lord Rickard, described as originating from
"the wolf blood".
Brandon shared this trait with his sister,
Lyanna, and Eddard believes this led them
both to early deaths. Brandon was the best
swordsman among his siblings, and an excellent
jouster.
He loved to hone his sword, preferring it
to be as sharp as possible. He also loved
to ride.
Born in 262 AC at Winterfell, Brandon was
the eldest son and heir of Lord Rickard and
Lady Lyarra Stark.
Rickard was the head of House Stark and Lord
Paramount of the North,
the Warden of the North and head of House
Stark until he was executed
along with his eldest son and heir Brandon
by the Mad King, Aerys II Targaryen.
The North is one of the constituent regions
of the Seven Kingdoms
and House Stark is one of the Great Houses
of the realm.
House Stark rules the region from their seat
of Winterfell
and Rickard also held the title Lord of Winterfell.
Rickard was the father of Brandon, Eddard,
Lyanna and Benjen Stark.
Both Rickard Stark and the Mad King are grandfathers
to Jon Snow.
Rickard Stark served faithfully under King
Aerys II.
He was saved from drowning by Ser Arthur Dayne
during the siege of White Harbor by the outlaw
Sea Kings. He arranged for the betrothal of
his daughter Lyanna Stark to Robert Baratheon,
the Lord Paramount of the Stormlands. He also
betrothed his son and heir Brandon Stark to
Catelyn Tully, the daughter of Hoster Tully,
Lord Paramount of the Riverlands.
Both engagements were broken when Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen abducted Lyanna.
Brandon was fostered at Barrowton with Lord
Dustin.
He spent most his time riding in the Rills.
His father betrothed him to Catelyn Tully
of Riverrun , who considered him to be more
handsome than his younger brother Eddard.
Brandon did not want to marry Catelyn,
but Lord Rickard's ambitions did not allow
him to marry the daughter of a northern bannermen.
In 281 AC, Brandon was present at the tourney
at Harrenhal.
There, he was introduced to the crannogman
Howland Reed by his sister, Lyanna.
During the opening feast of the tourney, Brandon
asked Ashara Dayne, sister of Ser Arthur Dayne,
to dance with Eddard, who was too shy to ask
her himself. Brandon later entered the lists,
but was unhorsed by Prince Rhaegar Targaryen.
After Prince Rhaegar won the tournament,
he crowned Brandon's sister Lyanna as his
queen of love and beauty, passing over his
own wife,
Princess Elia Martell. Brandon had to be restrained
from confronting Rhaegar,
as he took Rhaegar's action as a slight upon
Lyanna's honor,
since Lyanna had been betrothed to Lord Robert
Baratheon for a long time.
In 282 AC, Brandon was present at Riverrun
when the date for his wedding to Catelyn was
announced. Petyr Baelish, the ward of Catelyn's
father, Lord Hoster Tully, challenged Brandon
to a duel for her hand. They fought in the
lower bailey at Riverrun. Catelyn begged him
to spare Petyr's life,
and Brandon promised her to do so. Brandon
armored himself for battle,
aided by Catelyn's young brother, Edmure Tully,
who served as Brandon's squire.
When Brandon saw that Petyr wore only a helm
and a breastplate, and mail,
he took off most of his own armor. Brandon
was more than a match for the much younger
Petyr.
He offered the boy several chances to yield,
but when Petyr kept refusing,
Brandon ended the duel by injuring Petyr severely.
He defeated Baelish easily,
nearly disemboweling him in the process, but
Catelyn begged Brandon to spare his life.
The maesters were able to save Baelish and
he eventually recovered,
but he was left with a deep scar running from
his stomach to his collarbone (under his clothes),
a "token" from Brandon that Baelish would
always carry with him.
Afterwards he departed Riverrun, promising
Catelyn to return soon so they could wed.
From Riverrun, Brandon left to join his father's
wedding party, coming down from the north.
They were on their way again back to Riverrun
for the wedding when the word reached Brandon
of Lyanna's supposed abduction by Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen.
Brandon, along with his squire Ethan Glover,
Kyle Royce, Elbert Arryn, and Jeffory Mallister,
rode to King's Landing immediately. Upon entering
the Red Keep, Brandon shouted for Rhaegar
to "come out and die". Rhaegar was not present,
however, and Brandon and his companions were
arrested by King Aerys II Targaryen and charged
with plotting Rhaegar's murder.
Their fathers were called to court to answer
the charges.
Aerys II imprisoned Brandon and ordered that
Rickard rides south to answer for his son's
impertinence. Against advice, Rickard agreed,
assuming that the matter would be settled
through a trial
or a bargain of some kind. Brandon was killed
on the order of Aerys Targaryen, along with
his father, after they protested the kidnapping
of Lyanna by Prince Rhaegar Targaryen.
Brandon was placed in a strangle device from
Tyrosh, with a longsword placed just out of
reach.
He was forced to watch as his father was burned
alive in his own armor
and strangled himself while attempting to
get to the sword so he could save his father.
He was twenty years old at the time. Aerys
then ordered Jon Arryn to hand over his ward
and new Lord of Winterfell Eddard Stark as
well as Robert Baratheon, Lord of Storm's
End.
Having sworn a sacred oath to protect Eddard,
Jon instead rose his banners in rebellion.
He was supported by the North, Lyanna's betrothed
Robert Baratheon, and Hoster Tully.
This sparked the beginning of the war known
as Robert's Rebellion,
which led to the near-destruction of House
Targaryen and its removal from the Iron Throne.
Brandon was buried in the crypts beneath Winterfell.
Although only the kings and lords of Winterfell
normally have statues in their likeness placed
beside their tombs, both Brandon and his sister
Lyanna were given a statue by their brother
Eddard,
as he'd loved them very much. Eddard Stark
named his second true born son Brandon
(affectionately known as "Bran") in his elder
brother's memory.
Many stories we heard of such as Brandon almost
killing Littlefinger,
the Mad King executing Brandon and his father
Rickard Stark,
many battles we heard of such as the Battle
of the Trident
and the legendary duel between Robert and
Rhaegar during Robert's Rebellion,
all of that and more we'll finally see in
the upcoming Game of Thrones prequel, House
of the Dragon, coming in 2022 on HBO.
Let me know your thoughts about everything
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and hope to
see you in the next one.
Peace!